- [Waiter] What can we getcha?
- Directions to Belburg Valley Farm.
I'm the new owner.
(dish shatters)
Oh.
- In from America, right?
I bet there's an intriguing
backstory to your arrival.
- [Gabriela] Well, after losing my job
and my boyfriend in San Fransico,
I entered a Win an Inn contest.
- [Computerized Voice] You've won an inn.
Located in New Zealand.
- [Gabriela] So a 13
hour flight to Auckland
and three bus rides later
(horn honks)
(vehicle crashes)
(woman screams)
I'm so sorry.
I will pay for any of the damages.
- Well this did put a
big dent in my vehicle.
- Ha. Ha.
I'm officially the owner of an inn.
(goat bleats in background)
Ugh.
(rooster crows)
(wooden stair breaks)
Never assume anything on the internet
matches its profile picture.
(goat bleats)
(woman screams)
(two women scream)
- You look like you've seen a ghost.
- Goat.
- Gilbert.
He's a wily fella.
(goat bleats)
(upbeat music)
- [Gabriela] Do you know anybody in town
that does renovations?
- Jake Taylor.
- Can I have his phone number?
- [Storekeeper] Jake,
what's your phone number?
- Who's asking?
- [Storekeeper] She is.
- No I didn't.
- Why do you want my number?
- [Gabriela] I was hoping to talk to you
about a proposition.
(car doors slam)
- [Jake] She's a real beauty.
I can help you restore
her to original glory.
Brilliant.
- You see, broken.
What's with you and the old houses?
- Well I always took to building.
Makes me feel a little less
- Little less broken?
- [Townswoman] I believe Beechwood Downs'
most eligible bachelor
might be keen on you.
- [Gabriela] She's a beaut.
- She sure is.
♪ We don't care ♪
- Wow.
(upbeat music)
Hey, Ted.
- Diaz, guess what.
I got a brand new job for you.
(upbeat music)
- I do have my real life to get back to.
- Oh, your real life.
- [Townswoman] Seems to
me, you haven't told her
how you actually feel.
Upbeat music.
(shouts)
- I'm guessing the universe has
its own plans for things eh?
- I like to imagine a fairytale ending.
(upbeat music)
(woman screams)
(goat bleats)
- I thought we were friends, mate.
(upbeat music)